- On this episode, we come to
Charity: Water and get deep.
(hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
- Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 210 of
The #AskGaryVee Show.
I'm excited about
this one, India.
- [India] Mhmmm.
- We've a phenomenal guest,
dear friend of mine
for a very long time.
I know a lot of you in the
Vayner Nation will know the
organization and this fine
looking gentleman as well.
But Scott for all the people at
home that don't know,
who are you and then tell us
a little bit about where we are
and what you do and then
India we will get into the show.
Hope everybody had a
wonderful weekend.
I'm feeling good.
It's a nice day in New York.
- Sure, man.
Charity: Water based here
in Tribeca in New York City.
We've been at it for about 10
years trying to make sure every
single person on
Earth drinks clean water.
And unfortunately,--
- [Gary] And for people
that are undereducated--
- Yeah.
- like I used to before we ran
into each other, how many of
those people exist that
don't have clean water?
- So there are 663 million
people living around the world
without access to clear water.
So, it's about one in every
10 or 11 people on the planet.
Yeah, this is a
challenging issue because
no one faces this
problem here.
Our kids don't
drink dirty water.
Our moms don't
walk 8 hours with
40 pounds of nasty
water on her back.
It is a really
foreign problem to us.
But it's real.
It exists and it affects
about a 10th of the planet.
- And when did Charity: Water
begin? And why?
- Almost 10 years ago.
- Okay.
- On my 31st
birthday in September.
September 7th so we're coming
up on our 10th anniversary.
It began because
I saw this problem.
You and I actually grew up
very close to each other.
- Hunterdon County, baby.
- I moved to the
city at 18 or 19.
Rebelling against the
very conservative Christian
upbringing and I have found
my way into nightlife so I
basically lost a decade.
- He's gonna underplay this.
This guy is a legend
amongst legend in that world.
- So I got people drunk for 10
years and got very, very good at
the velvet rope and the one-way
glass and the great DJs and
all the right
people at the party.
Had picked up pretty much every
vice you can imagine short of a
heroine after a decade of
partying and just kind of hit
bottom at the top.
Realized that I had become
the worst person I knew.
I was morally bankrupt.
- You were unable
to look around
and say that guy
is worse than me.
- No, that is actually true.
I was the worst guy.
People don't believe this.
I have to go find old footage
and I find these old emails
sometimes that I wrote and
I'm just like what an a.
Like what a jerk I was.
I remember once I mean this
really, this is horrible someone
delivered food once
whatever version
I think it was Cosmo.com
back in the day.
- Yes.
- And someone delivered
something and they asked me to
sign it and I didn't, they
didn't have a pen and I spent
like five minute yelling at
them for not having a pen.
- Right.
- There's only one thing that
you need to do
which is bring a pen.
I was that guy.
- You got to a real bad place.
- I got to a really bad place.
- And by hitting bottom you
sprung up to a totally different
version of yourself.
- Big life change.
Came back the faith but
really interested in service and
service to the poor
and kind of living
the opposite values that
I was living my life of
selfishness and decadence.
I made a radical change,
I sold everything I owned
down to my DVD collection.
I put it up on a lot
in eBay like 1500 DVDs.
- Yep.
Which is big back then kids.
- You know?
- Give up all your apps.
- I even had multiples.
And then I wound up imagining
what with the opposite of my
life look like and that
would be service to the poor.
Serving someone
else except myself.
- I'm going to jump in here for
just for a second in the context
of the business show and a lot
of you that are, this man helped
me change the way I viewed,
I'll never forget it,
told me, "Gary, you're going
"to be the kind of guy
who's going to do really
"well and that when you're older
years you're going to deploy
"that wealth and do good things.
"Why don't you just
start doing it now?"
Completely changed,
not only the way that I give
but a lot of things in my life.
Very few people have been
able to penetrate me and change
me in any way, you guys
hear that all the time.
I even talk bout my parents'
lack of ability to
at times to do that.
What I find most fascinating
about that and this is for all
of you entrepreneurs and
hustlers because I know you
watch the skills that made him
the best at getting the hottest
models and the best bottles and
the best places and the best DJs
he has been able to bring that
marketing, that charisma,
that operations skills
to a world of good.
And I have been blown
away and intrigued.
That's why also got involved
in PoP, Pencils of Promise,
and other things.
Show me people that have the
skills that would work in the
profit sector and deploy them
in the nonprofit, cause, NGO
whatever you want to call it
sector and you'll show me a
place that I'm
more intrigued by.
Because it's got that
entrepreneurial-DNA-
hustler-ship.
Watching you navigate over the
last decade, getting the people
together that have become
involved in this organization
it's all the same skills that so
many of your trying to attract
to deploy success for yourselves
and for the ones that are
watching like myself that
you've gotten into a place
where maybe you've
scratched some of those itches
and you want to do other things
with your life now whether that
is for cause or things of that
nature, for your
family members, whoever.
Understanding deploying that
same energy and DNA against the
new mission at hand.
I've watched you build this
organization from afar with your
amazing team and so many of
the tactics, the strategies,
the executions are predicated on
things that are tried and true
in entrepreneur land and
nightclub culture and
things of that nature.
- It was storytime.
For 10 years, I told the story
that your life had meaning if
you got past the velvet rope and
you were sitting with the pretty
girls and the pretty boys and you
were popping $500 of champagne
or at a table where
that was happening.
- Yes.
- That was the wrong story for
my life and took me to a very
dark place and
I've been fortunate to
be able tell a different story.
That if you are generous,
if you are compassionate,
if you show empathy for others,
if you live your life
in service and your
time and your talent and your
money in the service of others
then your life has more meaning.
And that you find freedom
actually outside of
the selfishness.
When you serve others there is a
freedom that comes with that and
I was fortunate to
find my way out.
So long story short, I sell
everything I try to apply to a
humanitarian organizations and
of course no one will take me
because they're serious people.
- Yes.
- These are serious
people with suits and degrees.
And they've come out of huge
UN agencies and the World Bank.
So I can not get a volunteer
job and then finally one
organization said if I paid them
$500 a month and I was willing
to go live in Liberia on a
hospital ship, I could volunteer.
And I was very fortunate to
see that I could turn the 15,000
people in my club list that I
gotten drunk for a decade and
just tell them a new story
and they wanted to help.
So I'm running around with
a camera talking about the
problems that we're seeing,
the people that were sick,
the intervention of these doctors
who were transforming lives and
then I stumbled up
this water problem.
Where we saw
sickness everywhere.
Doctors were leaving their
vacations behind and instead
coming to operate and take care
of sick people in Liberia but
yet half the country
didn't have clean water.
I'm like well if 50% of the
people in the country are
drinking from swamps and ponds
and rivers, how come no one is
talking about this?
How come the biggest water only
organization in the country
10 years ago was raising
$15 million a year.
- Yep.
- I found water through health.
I later learned it
impacts education,
it impacts the local economy,
it gives time back to women.
Water is this amazing, amazing
foundational thing but at the
time it's just like people are
going to be sick if they are
drinking dirty water.
And in fact 53% of all disease
throughout the developing world
is because bad water
and lack of toilets.
So you get to play doctor to
half of the sick
people in the world.
It was a compelling
issue for me.
And still at it 10 years later.
- I'm proud of you, brother.
You've done some
really great work.
We'll get into more of that work
but India I think for the people
that are looking for some
questions and answers that have
hit us up on Facebook,--
- Let me just say on your idea
for people that are listening,
that idea of giving
while you're building it--
- Yes.
- It's traditional model.
It's the Buffett model.
Make all this money and then
in your old wise
age give it all away.
- Yes.
- The fun that he missed out on.
He's probably having
fun now watching
Gates spend some of his money.
You get to live vicariously
through all these organizations
that you support.
- Yep.
- And I know you've also
supported with thought capital
and I've asked you for
introductions before.
So even more the money.
I mean I would encourage anyone
listening to find something,
you don't have
to write a huge check
but don't wait until the end.
Because the world
is a better place--
- For a small percentage that
have been successful
the money is easier part.
The social equity of passing on
a relationship, the sitting and
planning and strategizing and
having drinks and
navigating how you're
navigating through the
organization those
of the real things.
India, let's get into
this very important show.
- Very important.
- Yes.
- First one from Taylor.
- [Voiceover] Taylor asks,
"What's been the biggest key in
"establishing
Charity: Water story?
"How have you been able
to connect so well?"
- Oh man, I think the biggest
key was understanding what
people thought was wrong
about charities.
And I think that's true
for a lot of entrepreneurs.
They start and say what
problem am I trying to solve?
- I apologize for a lot of
people and there are so many
youngsters and these are things
that maybe you just aren't aware
of one of the things that people
start really worrying about is
wait a minute if I give a dollar
why is the cause only
getting $.14.
- Yep.
- Why is the thing only getting
$.31 and you start unwinding,
wait a minute, big
salaries, bureaucracy,
politics, kickbacks.
Really gnarly stuff and that
is absolutely, take it from
somebody who came from very
little when you work your face
off to amass what you have if
you're giving it away to things
you really want to feel good
about where it's going and
a lot of people struggled
with that and I said that was an
absolute pillar for you guys.
- And that was
problem number one.
So 42% of Americans
don't trust charity.
Think about that.
We have this amazing
heritage as this giving country.
- We are the giving country.
- But almost half the people
that could give don't
trust the system.
And it's all around money.
So that was really
problem number one.
- I don't trust the
mainstream system.
- And a lot of people don't.
- I actually have said this,
I actually think you and two or
three others biggest impact ever
is that you guys have become the
cool versions for the next
generation and every kid growing
up right now wants to have
an organization that's more
transparent and that you guys
will all solve and tackle and
move the ball in your causes
but your impact on all the 13 to
22-year-olds right now
that look up to three or four
organizations are the most
progressive, that you have been
at the forefront of,
I think your impact
is far greater on
what you do to the entire
landscape of NGOs
then just the
mission you have here.
- Well, that was the vision.
The beginning was
to reinvent charity.
So most people just know
us through the mission--
- Yep.
- and I believe those
are very different.
The mission is to give
clean drinking water.
Make sure there's a day when
we are not doing this interview
talking about water.
All of our kids, who are about
the same age, are growing up.
- Solve it. Next.
- My team is not coming in to
their school showing pictures of
kids drinking nasty water.
That's the mission.
But you're right the vision
was to do charity differently.
Charity is a virtue.
There's a lot of talk these
days about good businesses.
- Right.
- There is a role and a place
for pure philanthropic capital.
There are companies out there
that are trying to solve the
water crisis through
selling bottled water.
They sell at $2.30 bottle of
water and five cents goes.
Okay?
It's better to just get a bunch
of people to give five cents
instead of buying the water.
I believe there's
a place for it.
- Like every model you have
certain people that start with
a good mission at hand
where buy one, give one
and then every huckster
comes along and here I want
to raise $15 million for my
umbrella company. Gary, good
news for everybody who buys an
umbrella I'm going to give
an umbrella to some kid
that doesn't need it.
It becomes
tactics over religion.
- But that was it.
100% of the public's money would
be the way we'd solve it.
We would go find a group of
visionary people who didn't
distrust charity and we can
get fund the staff and
the operations that
we would have.
That's a group
of 110 people today,
many who have been on your show.
I know you and your wife have
been long-term supporters of
that but it is a very
simple model:
there are two bank accounts.
110 people pay
for the overhead,
1 million people have been
able to give in a pure way.
So we say you don't trust where
the money's going how about
this: 100% of your money, we
even pay back credit card fees.
This costs us hundreds of
thousands of dollars a year so
if someone were to give $100
bucks on their Amex because
Lizzie and I you can give your
$17 and every one of them and
I'm not joking and every
one of those pennies goes--
- And we don't get 17.
We get $16.81.
- Yeah.
- We actually take your
money to make up the difference.
So that every dollar
can go to the field.
- Don't steal
those 19 cents, DRock.
- We just try to connect people
to the impact that was having.
Because money was not fungible.
- Yes.
- These bank accounts were
separate and they were audited
separately we
could track dollars.
So I could say to a kid, to your
daughter, she did a birthday
campaign, she can see actual
photos and GPS of those wells.
- Before we go here and
I need to move this along.
The birthday campaign.
I don't want to miss it
before we get into it.
This was a monumental thing
from afar from a
marketing standpoint.
- We got lucky.
We stumbled into it.
- But instead of giving the full
story you can look this up and
Google it but give
them at least what it is.
- People instead of throwing a
party or accepting gifts because
we have enough crap
and we get stuff
we don't even need
for our birthday.
And we don't
really need parties.
- It's your 33rd birthday,--
- you donate it and you
ask your age in dollars.
33-year-olds ask for $33.
- Right so you ask your homies,
you send an email, put up social
media posts instead of
getting me a gift, give $33.
- And seven-year-olds
as for seven dollars and
89-year-olds ask for $89.
This has helped a
million people get water.
- I was just going to say,
what has been
the impact of this campaign?
- The average for person raises
$1,000 from 15 of their friends.
So as an idea a million
birthdays could be billion
dollars for clean water.
- Right because not everybody
gives just $33 on
their 33rd birthday.
- Some add zero,
some give $3.30.
- Great.
- Every dollar goes in--
- Who's the first
person to do it?
- So I was birthday number
one on my 32nd but then this
seven-year-old kid in Austin
starts knocking on doors and
he raises 22 grand.
And then like holy crap.
And then Jack Dorsey
did three birthdays.
And Will Smith
did their birthday.
- And away we went.
- And away we went and
89-year-olds No-No Nguyen
gave up her 89th birthday
and wrote a mission
statement and said,
"You know, I'd like other people
to have chance to turn 89."
It's a really beautiful idea.
Our birthdays can help people
actually have more birthdays.
You can actually pledge
charitywater.org/birthdays/.
- Link it up.
- Even if your birthday
is a year from now.
You've done them,
I've done seven now.
Your kid's done one.
It's a great thing.
- [India] Half birthdays.
- Half birthdays, I like that.
- Yeah, I'm 26 and a half--
- and you raise on $26.50?
- Yeah.
- Done.
DRock, book it.
- [India] Actually this segues
to the next question
from Clayton.
- [Voiceover] Clayton asks,
"What should people look for
in a charity to know that
"donations are going
to a good cause?"
- Let's go very utilitarian
here because I got a hard stop.
- Go to CharityNavigator.org.
- This I love. Go ahead.
CharityNavigator.org.
- You can check out a charity,
however overhead is I would go
to Charity Navigator and then I
would read Dan Pallotta's work.
- And Dan's main book?
- Is "Uncharitable."
So there's two things, you get
the numbers of how a charity
spends it's money--
- And you can create more
cynicism by reading the book.
- You get a different view
reading the book saying that
overhead is not bad and
that we made overhead back.
We have overhead
110 people cover it.
- Got it.
- Then looking at how
much of your money
what we push for
is transparency.
I'm happy to give to a charity
where $.25 of my dollar might go
to a smart team
running good programs.
I don't want 50% of my dollar.
I don't want my
90% of my dollar.
- Let me ask you this.
- But I want to know.
- Let's take this tact
since it's slippery slope.
You know me
very, very well.
If I said I'm the marketing
genius of a generation but I
need the other 17, I need DRock
and he's fancy now he
makes movies.
I need $.50 but I'm going to
kill it you think you can wrap
your head around that?
In theory you could, right?
- Dan Pallotta would
and that is one camp
that says 50% is fine.
- You're so close to it but that
feels so aggressive but at some
level I guess the energy of it
could be, the punch line is
if you can feel
that the overhead
actually justifies
the mission at hand--
- But that's it.
So the transparency is
what we are pushing for.
So you might be willing to
write $100,000 check and
have 50 grand go.
- Yes.
- The problem is some many people
don't know how money's handled.
- That's right.
- But I may not be or maybe
you and I are both willing.
Maybe India you're
like $.50 is too much.
That's the only thing that
we have been pushing for.
I'm not telling people
to adopt the 100% model.
It works for us--
- Because you're able--
- the problem I was
trying to solve.
- Well members that
have covered your raise.
- That's right.
And people gived
for the first time.
I hear it all the time this is
the first charitable gift
I've ever made my life.
I just heard it last
week someone on Twitter.
Made the first charitable gift
of my life, A, that's a little
sad but that's the kind of
person I want who doesn't trust.
- I would argue it's not sad.
I think back to that 42%.
I was a grown man with a lot of
thoughts and a very decent dude
when we sat, forget about Omaha,
downstairs, me, you and Sacca at
that pool place and you said
that statement and it was right.
- Now you have
schools in your name.
And seriously, you've been
able to impact the world.
- And not only that to be honest
with you, I've been able to
impact other
things, not just this.
Sit on boards and
do other things.
It changed the way
that I thought about it.
In the same way that it is
my hope and dream that a
28-year-old hustler right now
who's made a couple bucks doing
Snapchat filters 'cause he got
my advice 40 episodes ago to do
that says you know what I'm good
at donate $28 right now and give
away my 29th birthday.
Or whatever.
And by the way I don't judge,
you do what you want to do.
You want to be 90 and
never give a dollar.
Everybody does what they do.
- You're missing out.
You can really have, it's
fun. It's a blessing to give.
We were taught this growing up.
You get to live vicariously
through all of the good,
your time and
your money is doing.
It doesn't need to
be Charity: Water.
- I get it.
- It's a blast.
Go ahead, India.
- [Voiceover] Melissa asks,
"I do work in Uganda.
"After clean water is creating
"sustainable jobs the best
way to see impact?"
- I think they're a bunch of
pillars people need food,--
- You believe once
water is drilled
it opens up the whole gamut.
- I do but jobs are
incredibly important.
Shelter is important.
Food is important.
Health is important.
We've just started with water
because I get to touch jobs.
We hear these amazing stories of
women who will use the time back
in their day specifically Ashley
in Uganda sometimes and they
will sell rice at the market,
they'll sell peanuts.
I was in Zambia--
- By the way, we're going very
quickly here, it's how we roll.
That's how this show rolls.
I know my audience
guys when he says,
gals when he says time
back these are women
who would walk three
hours because an hour
there, 30 minutes, 20 minutes
to scoop up the crap water.
Brown.
And then walk back.
- 40 billion hours are wasted
just in Africa collecting water.
We need to talk the workforce.
They did a study, 88-page study
out of the UN, every $1 invested
in water and sanitation makes
the community 4-8 times richer.
It yields $4-8.
Jobs are incredibly
important and that's one of the
things that's attractive to us
about water because
without the time.
- What's her name?
- [India] Her name is Melissa.
- Melissa, thanks
for the work you do.
- Yeah.
Awesome, lets move it.
- [India] I have one more.
- [Voiceover] Nayeli asks,
"What's the best way to
"fundraise for a church that is
also a community center with
"limited resources?"
- All right so let's break
out of our thing and
go more holistic.
- Yeah.
- One more time?
What's the best
way for a church--
- [India] For a church that is
also a community center with
very limited resources?
- The best church campaign that
ever happened was, I don't know
what kind of church she goes
to but this was a pretty young
hipster pastor in Seattle and he
was trying to show his community
that they actually
weren't over religious.
So he threw a keg party.
He got a local band and he
created a smoking section
outside the church and
they raised over $500,000.
'Cause the community wouldn't
necessarily have given to the
church but he actually
chose us because
we were not a
faith-based charity.
He chose to make a statement and
say our church community
we care about the world,
we care about clean water.
What we don't need to
do it with the strings.
We don't need to do
it with an agenda.
That message resonated powerful
with the Seattle community.
One of things now we're trying
to get entire churches to donate
the birthday of every
single person in the church.
Same thing.
Your friends Gary's not going to
give to my church community but
he would give to my
clean water campaign.
It's a great way to kind of
reach outside the
walls and build bridges.
- I think it comes down and it
was brought up
right from the beginning.
It's storytelling right?
What is your
community care about?
What is going to
compel them to donate?
You understand the context of
the people that are part of the
church community and you need to
understand the people that are
outside the community and I
still believe in the context of
the show and there's many ways
but in the context of this show
I think getting very aggressive
around Snapchat and becoming the
best Snapchat player in a small
town in South Carolina as a
church and then going to the
local newspaper to write an
article about how this church
is doing Snapchat better than
anybody it's always using new
mediums that give awareness to
your mission at
hand through your
execution of that storytelling.
And so whether it's Snapchat or
something else live streaming on
Facebook Live
for 72 straight hours,
something that everybody
in the world is talking about
use that platform to get you
awareness over
what you're doing.
- We had a fundraiser run a
campaign where he listened to
Nickelback for
seven straight days,
day and night. He went to
sleep with headphones on.
He raised $35,000 in
sympathy from the community.
I would totally agree with that.
We gave our Snapchat to a team
in Berlin a few days ago who did
a takeover of Charity: Water's
Snapchat and they were running
marathons and banging
on yellow Jerry cans.
Stuff that we would
have never thought of.
They were spray painting
Jerry cans, creating art,
creating content.
- I know I've gotta run and
I know you've got to run but
in the last two minutes,
what's that?
- [India] You're fine.
- Okay.
In the last couple of minutes
here what do we not cover for
the Vayner Nation to know
about you, Charity: Water?
- Ten years, you know,
we're getting reflective.
We've held 6.1 million
people out of 660 million.
We're about 1% of
the global problem.
- Is that crippling to you?
Since India said we
have a minute or two.
I'm sitting here thinking about
I'm very fortunate because I've
been close enough to watch and
we don't hang out every day but
I'm watching, right?
Boy you have hustled and for
me to say you have hustled,--
- 96 flights.
- To me that's a very difficult
place to go for me to like put
one on I respect your hustle
that's hard for me to go there.
I really respect your hustle.
For as hard as you grind,
for as many conversations,
selling people one by one.
Selling the story.
Biz deving.
How many flights a year?
- Did almost 100. 96.
- And these are not
like what I do.
Like, "Hey, let
me go to Atlanta."
- We've never bought a
business class ticket in the
history of the organization.
- I really watch from afar and
very honestly and this a good
opportunity for me
to say this publicly.
You did such a good job selling
me my level of cynicism
started off was like
when's the other shoe
going to drop, right?
We've talked about
this on a personal level.
I get it from the
business advice.
- And then I started having
kids and then we're good.
- It was interesting to watch.
For as hard as you've hustled,
for as talented as you've done
for all these crazy names that
have been associated for all the
big impacts the charity events,
the Gala in the different ways
you've done it, you know,
boy, for everybody
who is watching
that I say, "Patience, patience,
patience," it's gotta be a little
bit disheartening that you're a
decade in and 1% of the problem.
I don't believe knowing how
ambitious you are and optimistic
as I am as well.
- That that's good enough.
- I don't think you would've sat
there 10 years ago if we were
buddies from Hunterdon
and I said,
"Bro, weird thing I'm a genie.
"In 10 years we're gonna be
sitting with India and DRock and
"I'm going to tell
you, you crushed it.
"You gone as hard as you thought
you wanted to go and great news,
"you've moved the
needle by 1%."
- So it's tough.
I actually appreciate that you
ask this because most people
take the other tact.
And they say,
"Did you have any ideas you
would be so successful?
"Did you have any idea guys
from a cold start would raise a
"quarter of $1 billion from
"1 million people who
didn't trust charity?"
"Scott, you've transformed
19,000 communities,
"your community has.
"You've been a catalyst in
19,000 communities,
"in 24 countries
and 6.1 million lives."
And I was like, "Dude,
I thought we'd be 10X."
I thought it would be
50 million people
served by now.
It's hard.
As we said in the beginning it's
hard to get people to care, bro.
(laughter)
It's hard.
- You're right.
- It's not in your face.
Your kids aren't
drinking dirty water.
Your mom never
walked eight hours.
These people live
thousands of miles away.
You're not selling them product.
They are not useful.
The poorest people, trapped in
the water crisis are not useful.
They're not going
to buy our products.
- Let me ask you
a crazy question.
Another thing that
nobody would ask you.
I'm sitting here and I'm
listening and then I'm also
thinking about all the
emails that I get every day.
Emails that I'm on welfare.
I owe $400,000
for student loans.
My dad died last week
and I have to provide.
I get some pretty gnarly emails.
- I'm sure you give
to a lot of them.
- Yeah but that's
actually not where I'm going.
I'm sitting here and thinking
they're watching this and
they've got their own problems.
- Mhmmm.
- I sometimes think about the
people that are less fortunate
in my inner circle.
Friends I grew up with.
College buddies. Relatives.
This is a really funny question,
I love doing what I do in a very
narrow world with far more
vanity and less nobleness than
what you are up to.
No question because I love the
way it makes me feel by making
less money but making,
somebody emailing
me and saying,
"You've made my
business life better."
I get a high from that.
Do you believe and this is where
I am poking at the audience,
a lot of people don't have a lot
of money, a lot of people are in
debt yet they're very
comfortable buying a
$600 iPhone
while still in
that circumstance.
Just true.
Let's call it what it is.
Do you think it's actually
innately human
to not be wired,
this a really serious question
for me and I'm curious from your
perspective and I don't believe
you actually have the answer
I want your opinion.
Do you think people are
inherently, not selfish because
I would say that's wrong, but do
you think people don't get off
or get a high from giving?
Because I do and I know
it's my biggest advantage.
I actually think I have all my
things because I was blessed
with the DNA of
the high of giving.
I say 51/49 in
business all the time.
I genuinely want the leverage
and the feeling of giving more
than getting in return
because I'm good.
Do you think that that is a
actual human hardwiring that
most people they're
like cool whatever bro.
You're right it's not my face
and you don't know my problems.
I need escapism, I'm going to
buy Netflix instead of helping
some kid I don't know in a
country that I don't care about.
- I think selfishness is
easier in the default.
Being a dad now
seeing how selfish
my little human being is.
And kind of training him about
sharing and patience all these
like they're muscles
have to work.
However, I think the more you
give the more you want to give.
It unlocks something.
We talk here about
getting addicted to giving.
You start giving to us, then
you started giving to Pencils.
- That's it.
- Then you started
giving other stuff.
You're like wait, this is fun.
Now, I can give some time.
Now, I can give some connections.
It's one of those things
and is not about the money.
There people watching that might
be able to give five dollars.
- It's the energy.
- What I've been amazed by some
of the people in the greatest
need are the most generous
and that is what perplexed me.
We did a campaign early
on with Saks Fifth Avenue.
It was a very simple idea.
Right, women come in and buy
$5,000 handbags let's also get
them to sponsor water projects.
- You thought this was
going to be a home run.
- It was, however, what was the
most inspiring thing that Sachs
wound up raising $700,000
to their community
but the employees
in the Jackson, Mississippi
call center started
selling their personal jewelry
to raise enough money so that a
well could be built on
behalf of the call center.
- Love it.
- And the CEO was like,
"These people, many of
them are on minimum wage."
- Right.
- It's the rich that
are supposed to giving.
It's the women that
are maybe buying a
$5000 handbag that
would feel guilty.
No, and that is inspiring.
So you latch onto that.
It's the widow's might.
Those are the stories that we
are talking about
2,000 years later.
I think giving is an exercise,
the more you do,
give time, give talent,
give money, the more you do the
more you want to do and the more
it changes you for the better.
The more changes your family.
The more impacts your legacy.
Thanks for having me, dude.
- Of course.
Every guest gets to ask
the question of the day.
And a lot of people answer what
question do you have
for the audience?
- Okay.
- A question that you
would like insight to.
Your being, this whole show,
hopefully inspires a small group
to maybe do something instead
of that route is generally like
some insight on?
- Yeah.
- Hundreds and hundreds of
people could leave comments on
Facebook and YouTube.
- Yes.
So our challenge is we've gotten
1 million people to give once
over the decade.
We've helped 6 million people.
We start at zero every year.
January 1 we have to go
do it all over again.
We have to re-inspire people.
I need to go remind him that his
family is making a difference.
- It's true.
- We are trying to build
a monthly giving program.
We're trying to build a
subscription program and
innovate and we
actually don't know how yet.
The sponsor-a-child model,
everybody is familiar with.
30 years ago bunch of charities
said if I hook Gary up with a
kid he's going to stay for
10 years until that kid.
- Sally?
- Yeah.
Right, and you're not going to
stop giving $38 a month because
Sally might be
out on the street.
- Yeah.
- It was a very
powerful idea that connection.
We are starting with
a white piece of paper,
what does look
like for Charity: Water
to take 1 million
people who gave once
and get them to give five
bucks a month, a dollar a month,
30 bucks a month, a hundred
bucks a month and bring them
along for the next 10 years to
make a 10X impact?
And we don't know what
that experience is like.
We have 2470 monthly givers,
we just broke $1 million which
about 1/50 of the revenue of
the organization or the
donation revenue.
What is the
experience look like?
- What are your thoughts
as business thinkers,--
- Business thinkers,
what would you want?
- What would you want that
excites you to give seven bucks
a month or--
- 30 bucks can give
one person clean water.
- So 30 bucks a month.
- And at the end of the year
they gave 12 people clean water
we can show them what that does.
What sticks where you're at
six months and you
fall on hard times?
You're gonna pay
your Netflix bill,
you're gonna
pay your Spotify bill.
Here's what actually happens.
People will lose their credit
card and they won't
re-sign up for the giving.
How would we make that
such a compelling program?
How do we inspire people for the
next decade so that instead of
the drive-by,
hey I saw this podcast.
That's cool 100%
on a hundred bucks.
- What's the next scalable
version of the birthday thing?
- Yeah.
- Recurring.
- where we can count on it and
we can plan for the future.
We're piloting it.
We got 2470 people.
We'd invite anybody to join
but if you have ideas--
- I got ideas.
- We have a whole
team working on it.
- You keep asking questions
this man will continue
to change the world.
Thanks, bro.
- Thanks.
What's up guys?
Hope you enjoyed the show.
Please do I get to
link it up anywhere?
Is it in here or
is it down below?
Is it in print or in my video?
- [Staphon] It'll be down
there to your left.
- It's here down to my left.
Right here, there's a button for
them to subscribe to my
YouTube video?
Yeah, it's that
little buggy thing.
That's right guys, click this.
That's right, use that.